[Music]
you guys met on MADtv and you were you
work at that's right they're just very
shy about Catholicism they just can't
hold around you guys met on MADtv you
were you were a sort of cast for the
same spot is that I think that you know
that was that's kind of the perception
is you know there's you got two black
guys coming into a sketch show and
already has a black guy on it that
already had a boy that's everything
Spears was on the show and so you
thought that was just gonna be one I
think yeah I thought I was gonna get at
the end of that season so what we
started writing together during that
period and it seems like the energetic
one out of the two of us yeah if you
haven't noticed already right so for me
is kind of like you know when you see
like a shark just swimming in the water
and just got that little fish kind of
sucking on to the side of it just
waiting for little pieces of food to
float off that's me you're so nice now
you you guys write sketches together you
refer to them as Dukes do okay not do
you okay no oh I misunderstood yes much
more scatological than you thought yeah
so you're putting down your own humor
really when you when you do that yeah
you want to put it down before you pitch
it that's that's what we've found over
the years as a writer will come into the
room and I've been in comedy a long time
when a writer comes in and goes where do
you hear that yeah it's usually the
worst it's no way it's gonna get a lot
you can't you want to lower expectations
walk into room say hey guys I'm about to
roll some diamonds right maybe they drop
a Duke then throw some gold nuggets down
all right yeah
no you can't do that now your show has
grown in popularity your fans are
sharing bits online you think that's
helping the show catch on with young
people immensely yeah I think a lot
younger I mean we've gotten lots and
lots and lots of hits it's gettin it's
gettin crazy now it's like like 300
million hits online now of all of our
sketches and we we also you know we love
because we also appeal to like the
parents of the young people too which is
great we kind of like crossing the
family bound you know
yeah they're watching the show together
and what's interesting is when you see
younger people the MA CS or the people
that are sharing the other videos
they're always like and then they go on
their merry way but if you're an older
african-american male and you like our
show the reaction is very very different
there are fans no offense they like the
show but it's always like you know all
right young but how you doing it's good
to see them all right
hey I want you to know AI enjoy the show
man I enjoy the program but tread
lightly okay some Rachel material and
the older and blacker our fans are the
more they'll have to say to us this is
true it's like the longer the
conversation all right but keep it up do
keep doing what you're doing now
all right okay all right all right are
you doing okay man all right it's nice
to see you all right and I say brother
you wait on thin ice much all night all
right thank you you take care of young
man do you anyway like like I'm trying
to have a conversation over here you and
I are me keep doing your show don't stop
doing your show but members on the
shoulders a lot of people oh man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Norris E&P I just